we got a special supernatural video
today two of our patrons join forces
together this comes from the channel
Supernatural go mentions our friend ash
who puts these videos together all the
time and toasted toad who contacted ash
help aid in this video which is
currently titled cupcakes dad jokes and
influence you see over on our patreon
where we have a weekly Q&A podcast
podcast is determined by the questions
the patrons submit and we do TV show
reactions so we have the option for you
go watch the reaction highlights or
watch the watch alongs but either way
you get the option of both and those
shows are supernatural doctor who just
started up JoJo's bizarre adventures my
hero academia fully caught up on the
series the two heroes movie included
attack on titan death note Code Geass
promise Neverland Hunter hunter one
punch man and Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood and then there are series
where we only do watch alongs for them
and those are agents of shield Gotham
Cobra Kai season 2 stranger things
season 3 Game of Thrones final season
black mirror season 5 haunting him Hale
house and the mandalorian season 1 head
on over to our patreon page today and
become a patron eject
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Jared Jared
[Applause]
I don't think there's hope
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you say Tuesday
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
should be an epic series of just them
[Laughter]
you know Raiden and Grey's Anatomy
JDM jeopardy morning everyone
a filly it's like a law kinetics of
their hands are the pockets
[Applause]
stay tuned for strolling deceased
should we just this is this is how Dean
and or Sam I'll be playing the part of D
and or Sam on the walking dead and this
is how we survive
[Applause]
[Music]
say what they want there what's her my
god or let's start I mean there's
there's the usual things they got out of
yourself you know the dishwasher is
right there
[Music]
actually I see because I know you put it
in
[Applause]
she's like grab a towel I wrap it around
her shoulders I know you're super angry
I got it I got it damn his work how can
you stay man
[Applause]
why they told
to hang off
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
good
[Applause]
momily
you're pushing kids happy for him all
that bad timing but you know your crowd
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
if they have an incest what did you
[Applause]
with the busywork receipt messing around
over here and all my wins that's not
what it sounded like you said we would
be sassy yellow
[Applause]
[Music]
- jokes - wedgie damn shot
is that what you call it
I just want to hang what they should
come is that what you call it and
there's a need off through the concludes
on each
I think your question is going very well
by the way
[Laughter]
not
hey guys
[Laughter]
to become sanity
[Laughter]
the first part I can't I cannot no idea
what you're talking that people hate
when you do that yeah
[Applause]
don't you mean Sam it feels pretty
damaged after gas is influenced in
we know
[Music]
what's the question you mean like a
reach-around
my cheats hurt
God that was sake languages
[Applause]
there's been no cuts I'm just going to
say definitely until they're just too
tired to do that
okay we just cut ourselves off thank you
very much
that was my favorite series of lords
call it happened it's sitting in front
of two people
[Music]
and stop myself - thank you very very
much
you're amazing please
in hindsight the best part of the entire
charade was this is going to be a
serious question what a great setup just
make fart noises or somehow it makes me
you know sidebar oh this was what a year
ago maybe maybe two years ago when I
looked over Jared and I was like I'm
like and I was like I was like we plan
to pull my finger he had never heard of
that
let me a theist man I know and he's
lived his whole life without being able
to do that gag I think we were in the
car or something
horses fire because it was like this and
I was the only time that gas happens
what what and he's pointing and he's not
giving me a lot to work with
I mean you play me I'm gonna play you
what it was and funny he looks me he's
like pull it what my finger all right
and like tears streaming down his face
with laughter it was like a trigger and
made you fart
can I say and I mean I've seen they're
going like bullets
I can't sweat out the vein is coming out
of your neck like I'm not giving up on
this bit too far am i minute I'd say um
it was not too long ago that we were all
on a flight together and I was sitting
behind you guys reading and I saw I'm
not gonna say which one cuz I don't want
to incriminate anyone but I saw one of
you just reach across the aisle with
your finger just reach across and make a
pulling motion and then from my
perspective there was just a wave of
nauseating about 30 seconds later right
after the pole both of our hands went
out too so funny pulling however your
story is probably the greatest gassy oh
yeah story gather ever heard so good so
um so I had just gone out to Chinese
food and eaten quite a bit oh no and
that got on a flight a transcontinental
flight with my wife was a JetBlue flight
from LA to Washington DC and hacked
flight and we got up to altitude and
there's something with the pressure
change or whatever it just felt like
the excuse is right yeah first it's a
Chinese food
[Music]
what what what what follows in this
story was not my fault it was one of
those teachers I was against the window
not gonna like make everybody get up so
that I where am I gonna go anyway it's
an airplane
so if I rode whatever I just decided to
judiciously release small bits at a time
and it's the first time judicious has
been applied to farts too
so anyway long story short I didn't have
at that particular moment I might have
been tired or something but I didn't
have no kind of muscle control that I
hope for and it came out in one very
sort of bit one cat cat sort of gasping
plume and there's something about it the
quality or whatever anyway long story
short the guy immediately behind me
faints
[Laughter]
and flight attendants came up and they
brought a tank of oxygen and they
revived him and he was very he seemed
very surprised by the whole thing
and he said it had never happened to him
before and his girlfriend his girlfriend
tried to explain but kind of and they
said hearing her properly over the drone
of the engines they said no ma'am that's
impossible there's no way a gas that's
what happened in the fuselage all the
fuel is stored in the wings and then
anyway I fell asleep I woke up we were
halfway across the country pressure
change to mo Chinese food coincidentally
this time I was I tried to be more
careful I fell again again they revived
him again we laid it when we land when
we landed everybody had to stay in their
seats while paramedics got him off the
plane this can't be real oh no anyway
this is his girlfriend when they came
back she whispered again somebody has
gas but really like dramatically like
okay I've heard a big deal stop feigning
and stop the woman the woman sitting
next to and they said the same thing now
the fuselage the gas and the wings and
the woman sitting next to them yelled
out no somebody has to go to the
bathroom but now you can't get up and go
to the bathroom or make it obviously at
that point and now I'm feeling a little
embarrassed like being called out so I
just sort of played it cool at that
point yeah cool yeah what's cool at that
point
that's a good nail art story hello there
was PF Changs china bistro by the way Oh
get that you sometimes do this you oh
thank you oh maybe I don't want to hang
out with them anymore oh gosh it's just
weird I I don't like fart jokes the
physical gags of fart jokes and movies
and shows all that much but that was
some great stories I couldn't believe
what I was hearing I wonder if that's
exact infer Merce I mean I can imagine
it from me being so extreme in the close
quarters cabin and and yeah the pressure
of the flight and how that could be all
too much to take in
oh man I was I was losing it just
listening to that story I was like if
that's true what I want I need to know
the science of what was happening I
imagine anything you can take into your
respiratory system that's based on waste
can probably have a bad effect on ya
never herstory of that caliber related
to farts before and on the blooper reels
they fart a lot and those carpets
they're always fart has alot of the art
maybe me she's just on a whole other
level
yeah maybe it's just and then the last
episode we watched and that's and in
terms of viewing this video and the last
episode watch there's a bit or yes
whoopee cushion this is a long sigh of
all the days to catch this story it was
the right time for us to watch this
video they talked about other stuff
right there was a point during this
convention story real World War I was
laughing so much I actually kind of got
dizzy and forgot where I was sure this
was the most interesting of the
convention ones because they're like a
solid 5 to 7 minutes of just a joke of
just Misha and Jared laughing we have
each other laugh you can barely say
anything they're primarily just laughing
the whole time it's likethey laughter
infection that happened
just like one person starts the other
person starts pretty soon there are no
intelligible words just laughs oh man
I'm gonna totally steal that thing from
Jensen Ackles I constantly mess up the
dishwasher and I constantly mess up how
to put the dishes away
Olivia is constantly having to tell me
something that I did wrong with the
dishes and that whole thing with the
towel that is a brilliant bit that I'm
totally gonna April let me know how it
goes
we're normally we watch these so we can
get some behind-the-scenes stories and
whatnot and usually there's some laughs
to be had along the way but this one was
just a laugh fast the whole time yeah
they're usually like fascinating in some
way and the these were fascinating just
in a different way yes in a way that
wasn't so much enlightening about the
production of the show which is what it
must be like to hang out on a very long
day with this funny that these really
deep series actors have the most
juvenile kind of bro humor amongst each
other to to cope with the especially
where we are at in the show and the
heaviness of the stakes maybe you just
develop that heavy sense of humor to
mask Thea heavy emotional places you
gotta go I wish they were recording that
I wish they have behind-the-scenes
footage of when Jared learned about the
pole miner being like what are you doing
looking what do you need that's like I'm
surprised I have honestly surprised like
that's that's impressive that he made it
like until being a full-grown adult man
if there was some shade at the
walking-dead though they did there's no
time yeah there's some real shade but
what's the timeline of this because
Jeffrey Dean Morgan didn't join The
Walking Dead till much later yeah
because I was trying to think of why
they were maybe they were just poking
fun because yeah Sam and Dean have
survived so many impossible things that
they can easily say you put them in the
walking dead they easily survived that I
was trying to think like who the throat
Shae because Jeffrey D morning didn't
want to be a regular or supernatural so
that you went to the Walking Dead button
out of time lines too far off me it's
like he left after season 2 game come on
walk it down to like 2016 yeah yeah it
was pretty late in the game yeah hey you
know when they throw shade you gotta
listen maybe he left because of the gas
yeah like this juvenile sois
yeah I feel bad because this video ends
with covert of the real rejects to watch
their in-depth discussions about the
supernatural like yeah we often do like
10 to 20-minute reviews per episode of
Supernatural after we do the rejection
and so I try to compliment that when we
react to these by providing like yeah
yeah let's go a little bit in depth
about what they talked about here
especially sure behind the scenes I can
clearly see that this cupcake experience
is rubbed off into Jared's performance
that seems like when he makes mistakes
as Sam he's really got that remorse
just like when he's cleaning up the
cupcake I think they're they're so good
at working with happy accidents they
they really treat them like comedic
gifts and in the moment and I think
that's what's brilliant about them every
time we watch them these videos I always
say and I'm gonna repeat it again they
really should transition their work into
more comedy after post supernatural work
you know or like spoofing themselves to
some degree or something like that
because there they are so obviously
there are timing and their comedic
sensibilities they're so damn sharp they
clearly got wicked senses of humor it
would be great in the Austin Powers
reboots funny to think about being in
the crowd like you pay to go to a
supernatural convention or whatever I
don't know if you like for these cost
some money to go to yes yeah you pay to
go and then yeah four of ten minutes
Jared and Misha laughed for 10 minutes
we witnessed just like a sidebar that
turned into absolute chaos we didn't
learn much about the show but who was
really funny I think the biggest part of
the panel was when they talked about
farting see now that's the thing yeah
like you come for the behind-the-scenes
insights and you stay for like the this
could have only happened today at this
convention type story yeah this magical
well thank you so much ash putting this
together and toasted tota
I'm not sure what you coordinated with
ash on of what to include in this video
whatever you can contribute it thank you
as well this is a lot of fun yes and go
over to our page patreon page to watch
our supernatural reactions along with
everything else thank you this is a
black much-needed laugh right now thank
you
this was a one of the funny things I
wash in a while thank you
you